[Music]
you're the American dream
Rags to Riches
[Applause]
trailers to mansions
you are [__] jostling
[Music]
just to you
easy I'll just do that
[Music]
I'm telling you right now these people
in here are gauging whether or not you
still got it
I just wonder about the strippers
they're kind of out femming her with the
flips and the dips and the
couch
you're too distracted try to block up
all the noise
I'm sorry who are you
now see
[Music]
[Applause]
do you feel this right now oh no thank
you
I think I just fell in love with you
what does that mean he's taking over the
house he's brainwashed her
not a human being
star
[Music]
never trust a dude with a rat tail